there are over 2 000 individual firefly
species
all within the taxonomic family of
lympira day which is
pretty easy to remember and these
lightning bugs with their flickering
light shows make summer nights feel all
the more magical
and romantic but how did fireflies
manage to catch lightning in a bottle
the answer is found in the bug's butt or
more specifically in its abdomen
in an organ called the lantern this
organ is a set of specialized light
cells
all encased in a translucent exoskeleton
and those light cells are where the
magic happens
the phenomenon of bioluminescence when a
chemical reaction in a living thing
emits
light fireflies aren't the only
creatures that have this power
glow worms and certain deep sea fish
species are some of the creatures
capable of producing and emitting light
but the firefly is probably the earth's
most famous bioluminescent species
so what's happening inside the firefly's
light cells
what's the secret to its glow
in the 19th century french
pharmacologist rafael dubois
working with bioluminescent clams
discovered that there are two essential
components to these creatures light show
he named them luciferin and luciferous
based on the latin term lucifer
for lightbringer luciferin is the
compound that generates light
and luciferase is the enzyme that acts
on it today we know that the firefly's
bioluminescent reaction
plays out like this a firefly diverts
oxygen to its light cells through
its tracheals and those oxygen molecules
react to luciferin
catalyzed with the help of luciferous
and energy in the form of atp
the luciferin then becomes agitated and
excited elevating its energy level
and when the excited luciferin drops
back to its normal state
it releases that energy in the form of
light creating the fire
in fireflies it's a remarkable
phenomenon that's also remarkably
efficient
in a light bulb ninety percent of the
energy consumed is given off as heat
with only the remaining energy a mere 10
percent given off as visible light
in a firefly on the other hand nearly a
hundred percent of the energy is given
off as light
that luminescence or cold light as it's
also called
is produced in the light cells and then
focused by a layer of reflector cells
which direct that beam outward through
that translucent exoskeleton
but why do fireflies do what they do as
it turns out
bioluminescence has a number of
evolutionary benefits
helping certain marine species lure prey
to their mouse or serving as a defense
against predators
fireflies are beetles and so the
juvenile fireflies
live underground so we think that
firefly
light first evolved as a warning it's
like a neon sign that scouts out
don't eat me i'm toxic but in adult
fireflies
the purpose is a bit more romantic those
yellow flashes lighting up our warm
summer nights
are actually part of the firefly's
complex mating rituals
with male fireflies attracting female
fireflies of the same species
by flashing a distinctive recognizable
pattern
so those lights twinkling around you
switching on and off
seemingly at random they're just the
opposite a highly intricate
specialized form of species specific
seduction
in north america the males might flash
like just one flash
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
another flash
wait wait wait wait wait another flash
some species the males actually give
paired flashes so they'll fly along and
then go bleep
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait bleep
wait wait wait wait wait and so on and
so
females who are kind of hanging around
on grass down below
can see these flashes and they can
recognize a male of their own species
but for all the romance and magic they
add to our summer evenings
firefly populations around the globe are
at serious risk
those finely tuned mating rituals thanks
to light pollution
those love letters get a little lost in
translation
in areas where there's a lot of bright
lights it's been shown
that it's much much more difficult for
the male fireflies to find the females
and for the females
who see the flashes the advertisement
flashes
of the male fireflies and other threats
like habitat loss and pesticide use
have also put the population at risk
sadly in many parts of the world
there are other firefly species that
aren't doing so well
in fact they are flickering out and some
of these fireflies
are restricted to a very specific
habitat if that habitat goes away
the fireflies disappear they can't live
anywhere else
it's a story playing out all over the
planet and across the animal kingdom
but as lewis explains education is
absolutely key to conservation
of fireflies and of all at-risk species
if fireflies disappeared
a lot of the world's wonder
would disappear with them would you want
to live in a world without fireflies
i would not by increasing awareness of
these risk factors
lewis hopes to shine a little light on
firefly conservation
ensuring that these little bugs will be
able to dazzle us for years to come
giving future generations the chance to
spend their summer nights trying to
catch lightning in a bottle
you